[Music]
afternoon morning lunch ish welcome
everybody thank you for coming to talk
about battery so it's another year and
I'm here again to talk to you about
about power it's an ongoing ongoing
project and as you probably saw from the
keynote Dave talked about Maslow's or
his own version of the pyramid and I
think it's actually a lot is is in this
image battery is is foundational to
everything you're doing on your phone
right if you don't have power you don't
really have any of the cool features you
know the camera you don't have the
assistant battery exists to power all
the other things and it's a it's a
struggle for us and it's a struggle I
think for all of you as well is you want
to do awesome things for users and you
also want to save power so they can do
those things for longer and battery is
actually a really easy problem to solve
you just take just kill everything fixed
I'll take my promotion it's great the
problem is it's obviously much more
nuanced than that and that is a struggle
that we have internally every day
talking about power and what are the
right trade-offs for users and that's
always a really hard question and we're
gonna talk a little bit about that and
some of the things that we're building
into Android P to make it a lot easier
and so the the first thing I want to
talk about is where where is it where is
it going and this is like a horrific ly
simplified I'm sure some of the
engineers that they are like oh my god
he's showing this but you have hardware
things even like how much RAM you have
in your device cause a persistent drain
on what's happening there so what
hardware the OEM is selected what
hardware you're using how big your
screen is how bright your screen is all
play into that effect you have the OS
itself is the kernel being really
efficient is it waking up a lot is it
doing as I have a lot of overhead is do
you have disk encryption is that disk
encryption and software or hardware
those things all affect then your
overall power profile that happening
under the hood the next thing is apps
and services and this is where we're
going to spend the budget a bit of time
talking today obviously what apps you
have on your phone and the service is
running on that phone
drive power substantially largely
through the CPU and through network
connectivity and then the last one is
the users interaction with the device
itself how they behave what applications
they use how quickly they respond to
notifications or don't all impact the
overall picture of where battery ends up
really complicated topic we're gonna
talk them largely about the bottom
bottom-left corner today but the the
thing I wanted us to give is before we
get into that is what are the things
have we done and how does the stuff
we're going to talk about and P affect
the overall strategy so we started out
with lollipop with job scheduler and job
scheduler was a very powerful tool to
avoid apps just having to hang out on
services all the time processing in the
background but you could schedule a
piece of work and have that piece of
work done in a finite amount of time and
the OS could then have some variability
on when to schedule it next we did doze
and doze was largely targeted at cases
where you have your your tablet or a
phone you put it down you're not using
it you put it in a drawer and you forget
about it and hopefully when you pull it
back out and use it again a few days
later it still has a battery and those
was really trying to target that problem
and was largely successful at dealing
with that we didn't we had to go further
though and that was with doze on the go
or doze white as we tend to call it
internally because it's just faster is
that was targeted at phones and like I
have my phone hanging out my pocket I'm
not using it right now but I'm moving
around so I'm not in a drawer that is
then the next like step was how do we
get that to be a good scenario and
doesn't the go is trying to look at that
scenario of your phone screen is off
you're maybe moving around so you're
probably not wetting all your apps to be
quite as severely restricted as full
doze but you still need to be a little
bit backed off normal scenarios that the
screen is on we still needed to do more
and go deeper the next thing was looking
at background limits and this was
largely targeted at background services
as a whole now we've had jobs around for
quite a while we also were looking at
background limits for location and
trying to figure out what's the right
balance of applications looking at
location in the background versus the
foreground and should there be different
thresholds of what is appropriate really
good effect with that the only the only
downside if you will to what we did with
Oreo was we need two apps the target the
Oreo
decay and I'll talk about that in a
moment in order to support this and then
P obviously since we're here we're gonna
talk about some more stuff that we've
been we've been working on so the one
thing I wanted to take a moment because
we're mostly gonna talk about really
cool ml and other exciting things is
there was a lot of just brute force
optimization that the engineering team
has also done this was looking at f2 a
fast file system work this was looking
at how do we choose between whether a
process should be on a small core or a
big core looking at when we should do
CPU boost so that you have nice buttery
smooth sliding but you're not just
burning power when the screen is on in
anticipation that the user might
interact with the screen and these were
all a bunch of things that been done
over the years this is a set that we
just did it on on P and there's probably
more that we're trying to get done and
then the thing is there's still some
some of those big big challenges that
that of remaining and this is what we're
gonna talk about today is what we
noticed was battery drain was roughly
proportional to the number of apps you
had on the phone not the number of apps
you were using but how many you had
installed and I obviously that's not
ideal and so we wanted to try and remedy
that we also saw a lot of scenarios
where apps are accidentally making
mistakes like if you're working with
wakelocks you're kind of playing with
fire and what happens when a mistake
happens and usually it's battery would
suffer also some developers would be
really aggressive with with their use
case and trying to be like oh I must be
there all the time ready to go at a
moment's notice and sometimes that might
take a lot of battery to achieve that
and is that really in the interest of
the user and how can we help help
balance that back out and because the
last part is even when an app was
aggressive or an app had a mistake it
wasn't obvious to the user as to what to
do they didn't know the battery menu
gonna help me does it tell me everything
does it catch all the cases some of the
cases none of the cases and even when
you saw a high battery value now what do
I uninstall do I live with it
do I call up a developer and send him a
nasty gram and so that's something else
we wanted to really look into and then
the very last one that I mentioned
before is the Oreo SDK having app
starting that SDK to say I understand
how the background limits work I
understand how I can use jobs and use
alarms instead of
services as you probably saw there was
an announcement late last year talking
about targeting requirements for
applications on the Playstore if you
haven't seen that please go google that
and find out about it you should be
looking at it because those requirements
are kicking in later this year and
that's going to ensure that then on P
the majority the apps and your phone are
now running the Oreo SDK and all these
features are talking about work so the
the high level thing we're talking about
here is a feature called adaptive
battery which I think we've been talked
about in a few different talks already
talk about battery saver and trying to
make battery saver better and then also
additional restrictions around
background processing that we've been
looking at and this is also how to help
users understand when can I make it stop
can I have another choice other than
uninstall something in the middle
between live with it and remove it and
that's like this that kind of pyramids
trying to articulate here is we all want
a good power efficiency right we like
batteries that last a long time we want
really cool apps and we don't want users
have to manage between these things like
do I want cool apps or do I want power
efficiency no one wants to have to be
forced to make that choice it's it's
terrifically difficult I don't want to
make it no one wants to make it we want
just to work and that's what this whole
project is all have been all about and
so with that I'm gonna invite James up
here to talk about that the battery
thanks yes hi everyone good morning I'm
James I'm representing the deep mine
team today I just wanted to say they
were really pleased to be here and
working with Android and excited about
what we've built together so as a user
you shouldn't have too closely manage
how your apps behave on your device a
modern intelligent operating system
should just take care of it and that's
where machine learning can help we've
co-developed this feature with Android
called adaptive battery it intelligently
aligns app power consumption with app
usage apps can still run in the
background when they need to and users
don't need to micromanage
so adaptive battery uses the concept of
app standby buckets every app on the
device is assigned to one of these
buckets each bucket has different limits
on background activity and there are
four buckets ranging from active to rare
apps in the rare bucket will have the
most restrictions and we use the ml
model to assign apps the buckets based
on their predicted usage so for example
apps that are predicted to be open in
the next few hours I'm here at i/o so I
might be using the i/o app so the iowa
is going to be in the active bucket but
in a few days time when I'm back at home
adaptive battery is going to
automatically determine that I'm
unlikely to be using this app and put it
into the rare bucket so it's not
unnecessarily consuming resources like
battery so what are the restrictions
that are applied jobs alarms firebase
cloud messaging and network are all
restricted in Android P depending on
which bucket the app is in apps in the
active bucket have no restrictions just
like it is today working set has some
restrictions on jobs and alarms and
frequent and rare buckets introduced
restrictions on the number of high
priority firebase cloud messages
messages beyond that cap will be treated
as normal priority so that we batch
together with other messages to save
battery generally as developers you
should assume the background activity
will be deferred and ensure that your
app can work under those conditions but
one thing to remember is that once you
this device is plugged into power all of
the restrictions are lifted
there are adb commands that you can use
to test your app in each bucket to make
sure that it performs as expected you
can also use new framework api's to get
your apps current bucket at runtime most
apps should be fine if they are already
following best practices such as using
jobs for background work and targeting
recent API levels like Android oriole as
Ben just said this is going to be a
requirement for our updates on the Play
Store later this year so please make
sure you're targeting the latest SDK
versions so let's talk a little bit
about machine learning the model was
built by Android and deepmind
to predict which apps go into which
buckets now we could have done this with
simple heuristics or we could have even
just used past behavior on the device
but we found that machine learning
allows us to capture the nuance of how
users behave with their apps and I'll go
into some detail on how we built the
model in a second for those of you who
are interested in the architecture of
the model we're using a two layer deep
convolutional neural net with a
feed-forward neural net on top and this
is used to predict the probability that
an app will be opened in a given
interval you might have heard of
convolutional neural Nets before
particularly they're quite common in
image classifiers but we've used them
here to measure higher levels higher
level patterns of app usage over time it
turns out they're pretty good at that
now all of this is happening on device
using tensorflow and that's actually a
first for deep mind we've never deployed
a production models on the compute power
of a single device and a single mobile
device with the limited compute power
that's available is a particular set of
challenges and of course we're building
this machine learning model with the
intention of attempting to save power
and if we are doing machine learning on
device we have to be careful that we're
not spending more power than we are
saving
we're going to be making this model
available to all device manufacturers so
they can take it if they wish for their
devices on Android P or they can
implement their own or they can take an
Android open source version of it as
well so the model we train the model on
millions of sequences of app opens and
transitions to discover the patterns of
how users behave so an example would be
if you use an app at 8 o'clock in the
morning every morning you're probably
quite likely to open it tomorrow at 8
o'clock as well but if you only use a
certain app on weekends like a game or a
travel app then you're probably not
going to open it on Monday morning and
the model is able to capture this nuance
the model looks at the users behavior
and outputs a probability of when you're
next going to open a particular app the
model compares the usage to the patterns
we've observed in the data and the
behavior on device will influence the
predictions given by the model so we've
also built this model with certain
principles in mind we tried to make it
fair
there is no favoritism of one app over
another if you use one particular app in
exactly the same way that I use a
different app then the model will output
the same predictions and they will be
assigned to the same bucket it's privacy
sensitive there's no personally
identifiable information used by the
model both when it's trained and when it
runs on the device the model only
compares the app usage on device to our
known sequences of millions of app
transitions and it predicts when you're
next going to use that app so if you
combine the app standby buckets and
their restrictions with this model that
predicts when you're next going to open
the apps that's the adaptive battery
feature it's a system that adapts the
phone
to you the output of the model is used
to personalize the OSS behavior to adapt
it to how you use the phone so the apps
that you use get to run in the
background and the apps that you don't
don't we hope this will create a more
consistent battery experience for users
I'm now going to pass over to Madan
who's a product manager on Android to
talk about the battery saver features
thanks very much thank you James
so let's talk about battery saver many
offer is actually run through the day
and as we end towards the day we
realized that oh I won't be able to
actually make it and battery saver is
there to actually save you remember
those red bars when our animations that
were janky in Oreo who liked those so we
got rid of them we also actually turned
off location that helps battery in
addition to that many device specific
features like ambient display as an
example are also turned off all of these
add up in order to save battery and
prolong the device battery so that you
can go back and charge the device we
have also made some changes in the UI so
that you can live on this mode for
longer now you have a slider that you
can actually increase all the way to the
right which probably allows you to stay
on this mode if you choose to but what's
also interesting is what we found is if
an app is being used by the user in this
mode having a dark theme really helps
our internal tests show that apps using
dark theme save power
compared with the ones that don't so if
you are a developer that already
supports dark theme please do think
about switching to dark theme when you
detect that the device is in battery
saver
there are few commands that he can use
through ADB to force the you force the
device into battery saver and test them
and for those of you who already support
dart mode there are api's like East
Power Save mode and a broadcast that you
can use to switch your device your app
theme to dark so let's jump into the
battery settings itself we think when a
user actually goes into a battery
settings probably they are having a bad
battery day you want to make the user
very easy to take actions you want to
keep the UI simplified and we will tell
you exactly what applications might be
causing their battery drain so will be
much more opinionated about these things
and in addition to that as you scroll
down we'll also be able to see how long
your battery will last and that number
is also powered by an ml model so let's
jump into that opinionated background
restrictions so we have some principles
upon which we have built this particular
feature user asks for controls they want
to know like which app is doing what so
that they can take a quick action on
them we also want to make sure that apps
that don't necessarily target Oreo or
also be well managed by the user and
lastly our goal is to make sure that
apps don't get restricted in the first
place so that way apps fundamentally are
a better battery citizens so with P we
will actually launch this feature with
two specific criteria the first one is
if your app is still not targeting Oreo
and has a background service the second
one is if an app holds wakelocks or what
we call a stuck wakelocks for more
than an hour in the background both of
these are very well understood causes
for battery drain there are more such
reasons we today present those reasons
within play developer console and we
call them Android white O's so we are in
the future going to be looking at many
such signals in order to incorporate
into coming up with new rules for
background restrictions so what does it
mean for your app in case if the user
decides to restrict them as James talked
about Jobs alarm services and network
the apps will not be able to do any of
those in the background there are some
explicit intent for example location
will not be delivered to those
applications so you're trying to
minimize the reasons why an app should
be able to use device resources when it
is in the background and lastly if an
app is in the background and restricted
it won't be able to use foreground
services so as I spoke earlier I hope
many of you are already familiar with
Android white O's if not I would
strongly recommend you to go take a look
into what signals do we actually show in
there today and how your app is behaving
we have heard many success stories of
application developers using this data
in order to improve their applications
and we in fact use some of these signals
internally also to make OS better trying
to figure out like what kind of changes
we could be making in order to have the
right guardrails within the oIA's to
make sure that app necessarily don't
accidentally drain battery there was a
session about it
if you haven't had a chance to listen to
those please take a look at the
recording
so we made the UI simplify but there
might be several of you who would fall
into as power users so you do like
graphs and you do like number or
percentages so we do have it in the
overflow menu now the graph is improved
by our better predictions and the user
can take action from this screen if you
see any app that is not necessarily that
surprises you as being consuming more
battery so from here you can directly
preemptively restrict applications or
unresting them this is a good user
control for users to have so how do you
test for this again there is adb
commands that you can use to put your
app to a restricted state or
unrestricted and test them while they
are in the state note that even an app
that has been restricted could still be
used by the user by launching them
explicitly so you want to make sure that
they still work so we have gone through
some of the key features in P and what
does it mean for you as an app developer
to continue to actually deliver your
feature using various affordances the
Doyles offers like jobs alarms and so on
and so forth what does it mean for you
to do a background work you might have
actually seen this flowchart before been
presented last year it literally went
through what is it that you want to do
and offer it some choices we want to
simplify our recommendation and thanks
to jetpack in it we have a great tool so
it's extremely simplified now hopefully
so if you want to think about doing
anything in the background we highly
recommend you to actually evaluate work
manager as a go-to thing and if you
think it is something that is really
important and must happen now of course
you have
the ability to use foreground services
but note that if you use foreground
services you have to tell the user why
you are using it for because there will
be a notification and you'll have to
justify yourself as to why you think it
is important and now because of that if
you change your mind go back to work
manager so if none of this work think
about actually doing the work when the
app actually is launched and being
actively used by the user so the choices
are hopefully very simplified all of
this really helped us manage battery
better and that will lead to having a
better battery life there have been some
sessions that have already happened so I
wanna call shout out to the jetpack
which talks about work manager there was
also a session on Android vitals and
there is a dev byte video there is a
detailed documentation of the features
that we talked about please head over to
DDOT android.com slash power and thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]